[Music]
there is a bizarre new interview i have
never seen anything like this
with infowars conspiracy theorist alex
jones this is the first interview that
i'm aware of that alex jones has given
since the nearly 50 million dollar
verdict remember that the attorney for
the plaintiffs in the sandy hook
defamation case against alex jones mark
bankston joined me a couple weeks ago
we talked about a bunch of different
aspects of the trial alex jones has now
given an interview to andrew callahan
from channel 5.
it almost seems like an act so i mean
this is the way that i would say it
this is either
an act or very serious mental illness by
alex jones i don't know which one
maybe you can figure it out but he seems
very ill to me
saying he killed
the victims of sandy hook do you feel
responsible for what happened to the
sandy hook families yes i killed the
children
but beyond that no i mean i went in that
school i pulled a gun out and i shot
every one of them myself i mean i'm i'm
i'm guilty it's true no but i don't know
let's just
do i feel responsible that someone
on on that played
video games on a bunch of drugs went and
killed a bunch of kids and then the
internet questioned it and i covered
that no i don't feel responsible and i
don't apologize anymore i'm done
i don't apologize i killed the kids
was there a definition i no i killed him
i killed him he didn't kill him no i did
no you didn't no everybody said no no i
killed him
i killed him now listen if i all of a
sudden had to come up with 49.3 million
i'd probably be stressed out worse than
this but he seems very very ill i
already admit it i did it i killed him
i'm the bad guy i'm the devil rid of the
first amendment
topics i don't think i killed him first
amendment killed him second get rid of
the second amendment get rid of the
first amendment they're bad they killed
the kids too george washington killed
him jesus killed him the whole we should
rename the whole planet sandy hook
everything it should be holidays
we should bow five times a day to new
haven connecticut for the kids that died
every american's to blame every gun
owner is a blame i'm to blame we are all
guilty to bloomberg and soros turn our
guns in turn our guns in i know i get it
i killed them i killed them i killed
them i i know i killed them
so i'm done talking about it
i killed them okay
can we talk about the trial at all
there's nothing to talk about let me
tell you i don't know if i can do this
interview right now
all right and then he then he uh walks
off
so listen is that an act i don't know it
seems like he's pretty ill is my
instinct and it's also understandable if
you just had a 50 million dollar uh
judgment against you and there are more
cases and more trials to come and more
definitely i mean
to some degree i would expect that he
wouldn't be doing well but it really is
a mishmash of a lot of different things
and as attorney mark bankston told us
when i interviewed him
there are many more plaintiffs and many
more defamation cases coming so i don't
know whether this is going to be
really the end for alex jones in
infowars i mean remember when he was
kicked off of youtube etc
we were told that will be the end
but then he fundraised off of it
and then they keep making money
and they keep going
so
i don't know if and what the end is
actually going to be but in the
immediate i would be curious to hear
from you
what we just saw
do you believe that that is an act do
you believe it is real
and mental illness
or do you believe
something else i guess that it's real
and normal
given the circumstances i don't know let
me know your thoughts and we'll follow
up